[Music]
how long we've known each other chin I
ever break a promise to you I will put
you in the driver's seat at LeMans and
just shut your mouth and let me do my
thing all right morning Shelby Warren
Molly
up yours now go to hell
and that's it folks Ferrari went to 24
hours of LaVon for the fifth consecutive
year
mr. Ford vari has message for you sir
What did he say she said for it makes
ugly little cars and ugly factories and
God you fat sir we're gonna bury Ferrari
at LeMond so the great cowl Shelby is
gonna build a car to beat Ferrari with a
forward correct and how long did you
tell them you needed two or three
hundred years 90 days who hates guys
like us because we're different we heard
he's difficult ken no no Ken's a puppy
dog
[Music]
and soulful there's a problem the
computer will find out get some scotch
tape and a ball of wool what are they
doing making your car faster
ten miles it's not fort man we're on the
verge of something and now you tell me
that I can't have the best man in the
world behind the wheel give me one
reason why I don't fire everyone
starting with you well sir the lighter
work faster that don't work we're
nastier
go ahead go go to war
[Music]
it's high-risk I thought the whole point
was to win the table tres
if this were a beauty pageant
we just lost looks aren't everything
[Music]